bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information locale édition du vendredi
aujourd'hui 18 décembre il sera question
de l'installation du conseil régional
d'île de france étaient ce matin jean
paul huchon a officiellement passé la
main à valérie pécresse élue elle
dimanche dernier elle est lauréat du
saint-quentin entreprises challenge
récompensés dans les locaux de l'école
d'ingénieurs l'estac à montigny le
bretonneux c'était hier soir un concours
pour désigner les jeunes sociétés
innovantes et puis comme chaque vendredi
nous reviendrons sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine les élections
régionales bien évidemment est également
la sortie du nouvel épisode de star wars
et les fans qui étaient présents aussi
sur les yvelines valérie pécresse a été
intronisé présidente du conseil régional
d'île de france ce vendredi matin à 10
heures à l'issue d'une séance dirigée
par le doyen de l'assemblée le front
national michel dubois a dans l'exécutif
réuni autour de la nouvelle présidente
des élus de paris ou encore des
hauts-de-seine pour représenter les
yvelines david douillet député ou encore
lui dit véronique côté millard nerfs des
clayes-sous-bois sécurité et emploi
seront les priorités de la nouvelle
majorité on notera dans l'opposition
l'absence de claude bartolone aussitôt
élu la tête de liste socialiste a choisi
de démissionner il restera donc
uniquement est député à la tête de
l'opposition ps à la région on
retrouvera carlos da silva député de
l'essonne il a été élu aux dépens de
livres chinois à benoît hamon on écoute
valérie pécresse
je crois que nous devons partir de
l'autre côté du périphérique vous savez
aujourd'hui l'argent public est rare
l'argent public est fier il ya beaucoup
de franciliens qui ont du mal à boucler
leurs fins de mois
nous ne pouvons pas gérer la région à
partir de tel particulier du 7e
arrondissement
nous avons cinq hôtels particuliers et
lyon d'euros de locaux dispersés dans
tout paris je pense qu'on peut
fractionner lisez tout ça et faire
beaucoup d'économies propos propos
recueillis par william elle nous
reviendrons plus en détail sur cette
installation de ce nouveau conseil
régional d'île de france dans notre
édition de lundi
et dès 18h invité aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau armelle d'année bonjour j
présidente de l'association elle aussi
qui oeuvre pour la parité dans toutes
les assemblées élues
nous verrons avec vous les inquiétudes
que vous pouvez avoir sur les futures
organisations des agglomérations au 1er
janvier
on le rappelle les agglomérations étant
amenée à évoluer avec un élargissement
peut-être tout d'abord votre réaction
sur ce scrutin régional n'en a vu en ile
de france c'est dorénavant une femme qui
préside la région est ce que sur le plan
des régionales votre association
constate une progression de la parité
oui bien sûr puisqu'on passe est une
présidente sur 22 régions à trois
présidentes pour treize régions
en plus de ça il y avait quand même 22 %
de femmes têtes de listes bon c'est pas
suffisant mais on constate quand même
que les électeurs sont prêts à voter
pour des femmes un moment où les
méthodes de liste donc il suffit que les
parties investissent plus de femmes aux
têtes de liste
après c'est aussi sur la question des
exécutifs des entourages
alors on va regarder ce qui va se passer
ce qu'on aimerait quand même c'est que
d'avoir une femme tête de liste mais une
fois une fois qu'elle est élue elle est
bien seul parce que dans les exécutifs
sont paritaires dans les régions donc
voilà pour moi les exécutifs sont
paritaires donc nous nous regardons
notre association quels sont les
délégations qui sont donnés aux femmes
bon ce qu'on aimerait bien c'est que les
les quelques séquences mobilisent
également pour l'égalité femmes hommes
qui au moins une délégation qui soit
pour l'égalité pour la politique les
politiques publiques d'égalité
femmes-hommes dans les régions sur la
question de la parité des évolutions
vous devez être plus au satisfaite de
voir en tout cas que c'est une femme
maintenant qui préside la région ile de
france quel que soit son bord politique
c'est aussi une femme qui est à la tête
de la région capitale de paris oui
exactement
donc maintenant on peut dire que les
choses ont avancé les citoyens tout
normal des liens des femmes elles vous
restez en plateau nous allons évoquer
encore cette question de la parité avec
vous dans quelques instants juste le
temps de revenir sur le premier sky
entreprises challenge la première
cérémonie se déroulait jeudi soir dans
les locaux de l'école d'ingénieurs
l'estaca les lauréats se sont partagé
quelques trente mille euros de prix dont
des catégories allant de l'entreprise
innovante aux porteurs de projets les
précisions c'est avec camille lambert
ever data verticale art ou six wind ces
noms ne vous disent peut-être rien et
pourtant ils font partie des nouveaux
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines des acteurs
récompensés le 17 décembre à l'estaca
lors de la remise des prix du premier
concours ski entreprises challenge c'est
un concours qui permet aux territoires
de valoriser les entreprises qui ont été
performantes vallat en particulier sur
l'année 2015 le jury composé de
partenaires comme airbus edf ou le cic a
dû délibérer entre les 97 entreprises
candidates 80 coeurs ont reçu leur prix
des aides financières pour mener à bien
leur projet vous savez c'est toujours
très difficile d'entreprendre bon donc
on est là pour limiter
bien sûr le risque
et pour les accompagner le plus loin
possible thibault lataillade a gagné le
prix porteurs de projets il a reçu une
subvention de 30 mille euros qu'il
utilisera pour financer deux emplois sur
le territoire
ce soir c'est un grand soir puisque j'ai
remporté le prix et ça donne un coup
d'accélérateur
d'autant plus fort au projet dans la
catégorie économie résidentielle si
l'entreprise verticale art qui a raflé
la mise
la structure compte aujourd'hui 2500
abonnés avec les aides financières
verticale art pourra se développer pour
devenir la plus grande salle de france
ce concours nous at elle proposé il ya
il ya une deux ans environ on était sur
un projet on n'avait pas de concret un
pas de chiffres concrets dans bush
contre est donc comme on l'a dit on
voulait c'était un petit peu une
revanche et vers data et 6 wind ont
respectivement été récompensé dans les
catégories entreprise innovante et coup
de coeur du jury
en plus de leur prix le groupe airbus
partagera une cagnotte de 100 mille
euros entre les quatre vainqueurs
une manière de soutenir
l'entrepreneuriat de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nouveau cheval
de bataille de l'agglomération voilà
pour ces prix remis par l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines et sept
intercommunalités et des autres
d'ailleurs on va en parler maintenant
donc avec armelle d'année pour elle
aussi votre association qui décerne les
marianne de la parité dans les opci les
opci ce sont ces agglomérations ces
communautés de communes au 1er janvier
2016 elles vont bon nombre nombre
d'entre elles évolué ainsi à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de nouvelles
communes vont s'ajouter maurepas à
plaisir les claies la verrière
coignières ou encore villepreux des
communes qui vont désigner des élus pour
siéger et donc dans cette super instance
et tout ça ça vous inquiète pour ensuite
regarder quelle place sera réservée aux
femmes
oui alors justement nous avons fait
c'est marianne de la parité
pour m
pour mettre en avant les opci pour pour
récompenser celles qui ont le mieux mise
en oeuvre la parité donc ça nous l'avons
fait par région les prix n'ont pas
encore été tous déserté nous sommes en
cours et dont la plupart va être nous
avons commencé en décembre et la plupart
vont être décernés en janvier alors
pourquoi nous avons fait donc une étude
au niveau national et pourquoi cette
étude en 2015
justement parce qu'il va y avoir des
changements en 2016 et 2017 puisque va y
avoir beaucoup de fusion de
recomposition de pc et donc nous
voulions avoir une image en 2005 de la
part des femmes dans les interdire en
2015 par un monde issu des élections de
2014 donc avec application de la loi de
2013 alors on constate que bahia qu'il
ya eu 8 % de femmes présidentes est à
peu près presque 20% de femmes
vice-présidente presque 35% de femmes
conseillère communautaire au cours de
notre étude on se rend compte qu'il a à
peu près 20% des exécutifs 100 femmes
donc en fait les intercommunalités sont
les dernières assemblées locales où il
n'y a pas la parité puisque en 2015 via
la parité au niveau des assemblées
départementales
donc ce sont les dernières or elles ont
un énorme pouvoir local puisque elles
consentent à peu près 80% des
investissements des régions et des
communes
donc là il n'y a pas de on peut dire
qu'il ya très peu de contraintes
paritaire il ya simplement pour les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants qui
doivent présenter une liste paritaire de
conseillers communautaires mais enfin
vous savez qu'il ya vingt-huit mille
communes à peu près qui en moins de 1000
habitants
donc les résultats ne sont pas
satisfaisants donc nous faisons cette
étude nous récompensons donc dead des
intercommunalités nous avons commencé en
ile-de-france dans l'essonne récompensé
une intercommunalité c'est celle du
tourtour d'année en hurepoix voilà donc
prévenus les femmes non elle n'est pas
non elle n'est pas été bien placé mais
elle n'a pas été récompensée puisque le
parc catégorie nous donnons trois prix
donc saint quentin les plus tôt
quatrième au pied du podium
donc c'est pas mauvais non non c'est pas
au pied du podium comme ça c'est pour la
partie pour l'étude que vous avez menées
sur sur 2015 donc sur ces les
agglomérations telles qu'elles ont été
désignés
la sortie des urnes après les élections
si pâle sauf que maintenant vous l'avez
dit ça va évoluer 1er janvier dans le
cadre de décisions du gouvernement il y
aura des réorganisations des
agglomérations comme saint quentin en
yvelines je disais tout à l'heure qui va
s'élargir et là il ya toutes les raisons
de s'inquiéter on peut voir encore moins
de femmes éventuellement alors oui enfin
il semblerait que 65% des
intercommunalités sont touchés par ce
phénomène de recomposition et comme
comme il ya des fusions on va donc élire
moins de conseillers communautaires et
va y avoir réélection des président
réélection des vice-présidents et là on
a peur vraiment qu'au niveau des
exécutifs les femmes disparaissent que
ça soit en interne on leur précise les
électeurs vont pas retourner aux ordres
pourtant voilà non mes mains c'est en
interne les communes qui refont les
élections vont toujours pour les
communes de plus de 1000 habitants
c'est toujours des listes paritaires
pour pour nommer les délégués
communautaires
voilà donc on a on a vraiment peur
qu'est ce qui pourrait changer tout ça
il faut des obligations légales
oui je pense qu'il faut changer le mode
de scrutin
nous ce qu'on aimerait c'est un mode de
scrutin de liste un mode de scrutin de
liste universel quoi en fait il ya eu
lors de la discussion de la loi nôtre il
ya madame à perret qui a la députée mme
adama perret qui a proposé un amendement
qui proposait justement ce mode de
scrutin mais malheureusement
l'amendement a été rejeté au niveau de
la commission mixte paritaire parce que
les maires sénateurs et maires députés
étaient un peu tout ce contre voilà il
n'ya pas une majorité disant voilà mais
nous nous ne voudrions que d'ici 2020 ça
change
bon en fait dans l'amendement il fallait
proposer un mode de scrutin d'ici 2017
donc je pense que le temps est court
mais je pense que d'ici 2020 on a le
temps de faire quelque chose
les élections alors on peut voir évoluer
la situation est vrai que le mode de
scrutin change d'ici 2020 sinon la
situation n'a pas changé on voit bien
que pour les mères sont à 84 % des
hommes ça a évolué de 2% entre 2008 et
2014 donc c'est pas beaucoup si on
attend que ça évolue 2% la place des
femmes dans les intercours m'enfin
champions donc on en revient toujours à
ça ça passe forcément par des lois pour
faire évoluer les mentalités d'abord
l'imposer et ensuite voilà pas de moi ou
il y aura un scrutin de liste
universelle la parité sera dans le
renforcement des listes de paritaire
pour tout le monde
alors justement ce que l'on va faire
suite à cette étude que l'on que l'on
termine on va présenter un bilan en 2016
et ce bilan sera présenté lors d'un
colloque au sénat qui sera le 24 mars
2016 et à cette occasion nous allons y
aurait une table ronde avec des experts
des parlementaires et des présidents et
présidentes d'intercommunalité pour
discuter justement de la suite qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire d'ici 2020 le sentiment
quand vous avez écouté mais pas
forcément entendu parler politique ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que pour se
donner bonne conscience députés
sénateurs et nous les avons reçoit
l'instant il apprécie pas le travail
mais la pluie mais ils appliquent la loi
pour l'instant mais pour aller au delà
oui oui mais voilà je pense que bon il y
avait un problème de calendrier
c'est à dire qu'il ya toujours le
problème entre la proximité des mères
qui veulent garder comme aime le pouvoir
proche
et puis quand même avoir une masse
suffisante de pouvoir pour faire pour
agir pour investir et pour agir parce
que pour ma lettre que nous voir s'il
manquait quel pouvoir vous vous avez
avec votre association pour influencer
un petit peu les choses
aujourd'hui parce que l'association
existe depuis longtemps mais quand même
bien supplice le rectangle depuis 20 ans
est englobée dans ce que vous n'avez pas
on mène un lobbying auprès des
parlementaires mais on fait aussi des
actions locales pour pour encourager les
femmes se présenter aux élections
locales justement pour qu'elle démarre
une carrière politique et qu'elle
continue ensuite donc là vous allez
publier donc on continue à récompenser
pour les métis et agglomérations
différentes régions 15e et puis l'étude
qui se poursuit et début 2016 le
colloque au sénat
exactement aussi pour faire le bilan et
nous aurons l'occasion de vous recevoir
à nouveau pour en parler plus en détails
je vous remercie beaucoup
armelle d'année présidente de l eau si
nous avons accompagné pour cette
première partie du journal en dernier
mot de l'actualité du jour avant de
revenir sur l'essentiel de la ce
manière le maire de la verrière a
profité du rassemblement des trois
crèches de sa commune à l'occasion d'une
fête de noël au scarabée la salle de
spectacle locales pour revenir sur la
situation de la pmi la municipalité
entend ainsi maintenir la pression sur
le conseil départemental qui envisage
une fermeture en début d'année prochaine
une réorganisation est annoncée afin
d'optimiser les moyens de réaliser des
économies
la protection maternelle infantile qui
se charge de l'accompagnement des
futures mamans et du suivi des enfants
de moins de 6 ans on écoute le maire de
la commune le communiste a la rage
pour l'instant je n'en sais rien nous en
sommes sommes dans une période un peu
étonnante puisque qu'on m'avait annoncé
la fermeture de la paix mis au 1er
septembre
je constate qu'elle est toujours ouverte
qu'il je n'ai pas reçu d'avis de
fermeture nous sommes à noël
donc j'imagine qu'elle sera encore
ouverte début 2016
je suis un optimiste dont je considère
que c'est plutôt un bon signe qui est
donné en tout cas que tout n'est pas
encore réglé
nous poursuivons à présent comme chaque
vendredi avec l'essentiel de la semaine
les principaux sujets traités dans ce
journal du lundi au jeudi zapping de
l'info locale signé cette semaine à
viège a pour l'instant on peut pas dire
qu'ils gagnent
ce qu'on sait c'est que va péter - tout
ce qui était prévu et que ces
attouchements
hier soir la droite francilienne a fêté
la fin de 17 ans de pouvoir socialiste
les militants ont pu savourer leur
victoire
c'est une déception ça n'est pas un
revers politique parce que encore une
fois je crois que notre nombre de voix
est extrêmement important nous somme
gelée guy le seul parti à ne pas nous
être déshonoré nous avons fait cela nous
arrivons à ce chiffre dans l'honneur de
façon unie et dans l'honneur cher
francilienne cher feront si j'aime notre
région mais je sais que vous attendez
désormais non pas des déclarations
d'amour mais les preuves d'amour et bien
dans les six prochaines années nous
allons tout donner pour on sait ce
qu'est la clé du second tour en ile de
france c'est qu'il ya des électeurs du
front national qui ont voté valérie
pécresse là où manifestement ce n'est
pas forcément le cas ailleurs en tout
cas en ile de france il ya eu des
transferts de voix du front national
vers bali pécresse en raison notamment
d'une campagne qui a été une campagne
qui a
du côté de valérie pécresse fait des
électeurs du front national la
principale cible en tout cas de c ces
différentes déclarations les a séduits
ça a marché
suffisamment pour la mettre devant nous
j'ai été voir le premier avec mon père
en 77 je crois ou
quelque chose dans le genre donc c'est
beaucoup de souvenirs qui n'est pas ce
fan de star wars j'ai envie de dire sans
même un peu plein les yeux quoi je suis
content ça fait dix ans que j'attends le
septième volet de la saga pulvérise déjà
tous les records 500 mille places ont
été vendues sur le territoire français
avant sa sortie dans ce cinéma saint
quentinois 2650 be ont été pré commander
sur internet pour ce mercredi
ce mardi les étudiants en bts
comptabilité gestion un rambouillet
découvre le goût d'entreprendre à la
chambre de commerce de versailles
venu avec huit projets de création
d'entreprises ces jeunes vont pouvoir
participer à la 16ème édition du
challenge écoles entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui en fait on va apprendre à
surtout pouvoir se restructurer parce
qu'en fait on a des idées plus ou moins
vagues et donc ces deux jours de
formation vont nous permettre de
vraiment rentrer dans le vif du sujet le
futur tiger woods est peut-être fini mon
teint benjamin jaillet tout juste 22 ans
vient d'intégrer le circuit
professionnel
le golfeur qui a débuté sur les greens
suit un stage organisé en 2008 par la
mairie de montigny-le-bretonneux
évoluera l'année prochaine dans le pro
gold tours l'équivalent de la troisième
division
c'est une tradition pour la septième
année consécutive la course cycliste
paris nice organisé du 6 au 13 mars
s'élancera depuis les yvelines
la ville de conflans sainte honorine a
été choisi pour le prologue de cette
soixante quatorzième édition
elle succède à maurepas au programme une
difficulté le sentier des laveuses une
cote de 200 m une petite difficulté est
assez courte qu'on aurait dû classé hors
catégorie du tour de france
mais qui vont arrêter plus d'un qui va
provoquer d d d écart à l'arrivée et
ensuite un parcours beaucoup plus plat
pour aller chercher la ligne d'arrivée
donc un beau décor d'ensemble je pense
qu'on va avoir d'excellentes images
ce week-end les manifestations pour le
téléthon ont continué de rassembler les
associations qui organisent des
événements au profit de l'afm le font
toute l'année et pas seulement sur un
week-end à elancourt le club de roller
et roller hockey proposer un disco
roller le moyen de découvrir la
discipline à travers des jeux des
animations mais aussi de s'amuser
une trentaine de guirlandes de semaine
d'installation et des centaines de
lumières
serge participent au concours
d'illuminations organisée par la mairie
de coignières sa collection
il a accumulé au fil des années tous les
ans on change un peu faux enfants un
change on change de couleur surtout
aussi une fois ces bleus blancs là cette
année on a fait multicolores et puis on
a remis dégonflant plus de chaque fin de
semaine dans ce journal les enfants
réagissent également l'actualité locale
et nationale c'est qu'en se préparait
avec les jeunes du collège des saules à
guyancourt
c'est un film que j'ai beaucoup aimé
j'ai particulièrement aimé quand j'ai vu
la première le premier film de star wars
parce que je les ai pas toujours encore
jusqu'au 7e ça m'a beaucoup plu parce
que j'aimais bien le style espace
vaisseau spatial hypers géant les gros
vaisseaux laser et tout ce qui ce qui va
avec
donc ça m'a beaucoup plu j'ai même
acheté les cheveux mal est ce qu a
ajouté le jeu est différent des petites
figurines et porte-clés tout comme ça
bassil des jedi c'était d'ela et sceptre
laser bonjour même pas vu mais en colo
un moment là à ghadames du passage ici
c'est fait un passage très connu il dit
je suis ton père dark vador j'ai vu les
bandes-annonces sa mère elle connaît
elle aime bien ta génération star voir
ça comment dire ça évolue logram fil des
années par exemple j'espère qu'en gspr
en 2003 par exemple ça sera mieux mieux
mieux encore mieux quoi c'est vraiment
un film que je pense que plein papin de
gens connaissent et aiment donc en fait
que chaque fois une générale nouvelle
saga qui sort enfin une nouvelle
génération de trois films qui sortent
ces permet à calais avec les pins akka
technologies qui change de créer encore
plus de stations de d'action dans les
films il ya des personnes qui dorment et
d'heure juste pour aller voir star base
trouve ça un peu bizarre j'avais regardé
une émission je crois ils disaient qu'on
n'avait pas le droit de publier des
critiques avant tel jour à telle heure
je crois 4 star wars faudrait trouver
quelque chose de
un petit peu normal qu'on en parle parce
que c'est un film qui va moins connus
mais des fois il ya je pense que vous
devez vous poser un peu lâché la laisse
du temps à parler non paix tout en photo
tout en moi je trouve qu'en fait que
s'il y avait juste il sert et les films
et les dvd chauffe que c'était largement
et c'est que ça faisait unique alors que
si on voit partout les joies et plus les
lego star wars est tout près c'est plus
trop d'intérêts le jeu c'est pas
vraiment un stade c'est pas vraiment un
star wars enfin c'est pas star wars star
wars quoi c'est un jeu qui est vraiment
dérivés de du film parce que tu n'as pas
les mêmes effets spéciaux les graphismes
sont pas pareils dans le film c'est pas
les mêmes missions n'y a rien qui dit il
ya rien qui paraît que d'un film c'est
vraiment un produit dérivé et
l'actualité locale revient lundi en
direct 18h sur notre antenne première
diffusion à 19h aussitôt en replay sur
notre site internet www.td.com 18 points
comme un mot du programme de la semaine
prochaine justement il sera question des
préparatifs du 4l trophy un raid
automobile humanitaire pour les 18 28
ans qui permet d'acheminer notamment du
matériel scolaire dans les pays en
difficulté dehimi noah s'apprête à y
participer en février
les images aussi lundi de la nouvelle
édition des féeries de trappes c'est
l'un des nombreux rendez vous proposés
en cette fin du mois de décembre
spectacles animations durant ce week end
et puis bien sûr nous en parlions au
début du journal l'installation du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france
passation de pouvoir ce vendredi matin
entre jean paul huchon socialiste après
17 ans de pouvoir avec valérie pécresse
pour les républicains dans un instant
sur tb fils vous retrouverez ces forains
à manille pour le 7-8 week end idées
sorties idées loisirs bonnes vacances
pour ceux qui sont déjà bon courage aux
autres et à lundi donc pour le journal
nouvelle édition toujours présenté par
florane parfait